hello and welcome to this video playing
of Wolverine okay we'll see nah he plays
this stuff okay I think you had we had
banker was before but not in a mood for
venko just play a possible maroc see
bind no he plays that line 9 to a five
you know it's not particularly good but
we'll see what happens um yeah we can he
can play this sacrifice but i'm just a
pawn up for nothing okay he doesn't okay
okay maybe I go waveform and just
prevent any beef I stuff ask him sorry
what this night is supposed to to do
them on a five probably not much mmm
what now is going for is six maybe I
don't know I mean hey Bishop g4 and I
have a couple of possible strengthening
moves moves that helped me a little bit
and don't don't harm my position
everybody is going for you six I think
and go i'm probably going to keep it
closed if he does know
yeah I have no idea what 97 is all about
but that's kind of known I never
understand what this guy is doing yeah
he wants to put the bishop people on on
that terrible day 8 square ok mmmm would
you like to break through in the center
somehow they'll have to regroup I have
to regroup Wow yeah i'm going to just
break through with the five now in the
long run it's impossible for him to
prevent i think the setup is so bad I'm
sorry I don't understand anything here
b5 is completely controlled that's not
going to happen and right on a5 is is
bad man i think i can start with this
and then play Bishop to e3
yeah I'm going to get e5 back yeah both
captures look fine i think this is okay
trading the trading the bishop there and
lining up on g6 probably i cannot
sacrifice just yet but ok i'm happy to
go to c6 of course if you lets me
ok so how to do that now yeah let's just
just capture and get this night also
close to the king 95-96 something like
that it's also Knight f6 threatened
which is not reacting to okay i don't
think i'm going to do that then you go
93 but I can play Queen d2 and pin them
so that's not going to help
he just loses the night but it was
pretty much hopeless anyway
black resigns okay so here we can look
through this a little bit this line is
this is some slightly questionable that
that line with 92 a five if black plays
that he should play something with e5 um
this for example um is something that
black can play he is slightly worse
because the night is a bit off but this
is a playable option a six yeah well
you're not going to play b5 he ever so
I'm not sure that this helps a lot to be
8 a-4 I'm just preventing this this is
for real now yeah look you hate many
many moves that I'm not quite sure of
what what they do and this is the sister
climax of that I mean this is I'm sorry
I'm sorry this just looks like he wants
to make fun of the white player I mean
nobody is kind of seriously playing this
kind of stuff people know what this is
Bishop to AAA this is like yeah like you
want to want to make fun of the white
guy no and well anyway when why just
needs to do f6 is kind of the same you
just have to put everything in the
center and then go eat 5 and black is
falling apart this is basically what
happened maybe there was something
quicker or anything but um what's
position is pretty overwhelming here is
full of weaknesses and I've got clear
ideas what to do Knights success 11
option I can also play g4 it's also very
strong how is he ever going to ya
untangle here against this night and you
will come here and so on yeah i think
what i did is this is ok it should keep
a big edge threatening Knight f6 well I
didn't react to that and then blend it
another night
yeah I don't know it was a bit of a
weird game but i always have played this
guy like 20 times now and the game some
always look like that he gets completely
killed and the only thing is i can lose
on time if I'm completely and economical
with my time spent other than that I
never understand a move that he plays
got kind of a history with him um yeah
it's simply not a good idea to put stuff
on the edge of the border in the corner
or kill your own pieces and so on while
White's position is completely
centralized and has many ideas breaking
through in the center h4 h5 many many
ideas and black is just yeah putting the
pieces in almost the worst possible
manner it's strange yeah thanks for
watching